. Rottenkastenhofer. Hey! Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Schön, dass wir uns hier beisammen zusammengefunden haben, um euch zu begrüßen zur neuen Ausgabe des Podcast-Projektes. Jede Woche? Zwei Hunderten. 257, jede Woche sind wir hier mit dabei. Vielen, vielen Dank an diese fantastische Einführung. Ja, wer hat den Vorhang aufgerissen? Es war T-Dog featuring Yo50 mit ihrem Intro. Vielen Dank dafür, es war eine Freude. Und wir nehmen dieses Projekt sehr ernst, aber ich habe das Gefühl, ihr nicht. Nö, ihr nicht, aber das ist uns jetzt auch, ich weiß nicht, warum du das jetzt so raushaust, als Erkenntnis, die grosse Erkenntnis der Woche, das ist ja schon ein bisschen länger so. Wir haben heute das Problem, Florian hat zu viel gegessen, ich habe zu wenig gegessen. Richtig, wir müssten eigentlich den fütternden Vogel, die fütternde Vogelmutter machen. Ja, eigentlich müssten wir die machen. Dass ich ein bisschen was aus meinem Magen heraus würge und dir einflösse, sodass wir uns ausgleichen, dass sich alle ausgleichen. In diesem Spannungsfeld zwischen zu viel und zu wenig gegessen steht diese Folge. Ja die ganze Zeit wird, machen wir uns nichts vor, natürlich nicht der Vogel-Mutter-Fütterungsprozess stattfinden. Vielleicht, guck mal, es gibt mal ein bisschen durch, ob nicht irgendwo noch so Röckergeräusche entstehen. Ich glaube, es wird nicht stattfinden, lehme ich dann mal aus dem Fenster. Und deswegen glaube ich, die ganze Folge wird in diesem Spannungsverhältnis stehen. Eine Dissbalance, eine Dissbalance. Mein Problem ist, ich habe nicht nur zu viel gegessen, ich habe auch, glaube ich, das Falsche gegessen. Dieses Klassische, man bestellt abends viel zu viel. Ja, immer, auch um den Mindestbestellwert zu erreichen. Um Mindestbestellwert zu erreichen. Man fragt sich, gerade wenn ich asiatisch bestelle, denke ich mir, wie viele Stäbchenpaare kriege ich hin? Mein Rekord sind vier Stäbchenpaare. Du hast für vier Menschen gegessen. Das heißt, der Herr, der das entscheidet im asianischen Restaurant, dessen Beruf es ist, festzulegen, also der ist ein einziger Job, der sieht die Bestellung und muss schätzen, für wie viele Leute ist das bestellt. Glaubst du, da gibt es so Masterclasses? Ich glaube schon, ja. Und das ist meine Masterclass. Das sind drei, das sind vier, zwei. Das sind zwei, nee, nee, der ist fett, den kenne ich, der ist zwei. Das sind zwei. Alleine, alleine. Hier bin ich mir nicht sicher, Name, Name der Bestellung. Name ist Melanie Kraflitz. Drei. Alles da, okay. Und wir wissen alle noch, nie hat jemand. So ein Künstler mit so einem Seidenschal, der so am Ende dieses ganzen, alle Leute packen das und wird das zubereitet und so, am Ende steht so ein Typ mit einem Seidenschal und so einer Brille und der sagt immer, drei, nein, nein, zwei. Für sie ist es eine Bestellung, für mich ist es eine Reise, die immer mit demselben endet. Enttäuschung, es ist jedes Mal falsch. Es ist immer falsch. Es ist immer falsch. Und die Masterclass besteht hauptsächlich darum, wie er sich mit den Beschwerden rumschlägt. Er sagt, sechs Stäbchenpaare, ich habe zwei Edamame und einmal die Single Sushi Box bestellt. Und Sie dachten, es ist sechs Leute? Wer isst denn zu alleine zwei California Rolls? Und dann mit sich dem Kunden rumschlägt, aber dann auch noch mit dem Chef, warum er zu viele Stäbchen rausgegeben hat. Also es brutzelt und brät an allen Seiten. Und dann natürlich noch mit den Beschwerden der Leute, die die Masterclass gekauft haben, die auch noch reintrudeln während der Masterclass. Ich zahle 100 Euro dafür, dass jemand willkürliche Zahlen sagt bei der Bestellung. Ja, sie haben die AGBs angeklickt. Aber ich habe es auf jeden Fall geschafft. Ich habe es nicht geschafft, meinen Rekord von vier Stäbchenpaaren zu brechen. Aber es war auf jeden Fall eine Menge und dann stopft man sich halt so viel rein, bis man irgendwie in so einem komatösen Winterschlaf fällt. Und dann am nächsten Tag sieht man das Schlachtfeld vor einem. Gerade, ich weiß nicht, viele kennen es ja wahrscheinlich auch, man macht alle Lichter aus, macht die liebgewonnene Serie an und stopft sich da sowas rein. Man sieht gar nicht, was da vor einem liegt. Klar hat man so ein typischer, am Abend Licht aus, das Problem ist weg. Und am nächsten Tag, wenn das Licht wiederkommt, sehe ich das Problem wieder.
Nee, absolut.
Ja, ich auch. Vor allem, ich bin auch so bei der Bestellung bin ich absoluter Connoisseur, Gourmet und denke mir, ah, Sashimi, was bedeutet das? Aha, die verschiedenen kulturellen Bereichen Asiens. Und die muss man natürlich, das Unagi muss man auch mit dem Bitterstoff der Edamame kreuzen, um dann gewisserweise das ganze Geschmacksspektrum abzudecken. Er leitet das Ganze natürlich ein, wird dann langsam übergeführt in Edamame, die nebenbei natürlich die Salzversorgung darstellen kann. Man plant das Essen so richtig durch. Man komponiert es. Genau. Es ist eine Symphonie, eine Harmonie der Geschmäcker. Und wenn es ankommt, Licht aus, The Terror an und einfach blind irgendwas in sich rein, blind in sich reinstopfen. Man benutzt die Stäbchen gar nicht, weil es zu langsam ist und man schneller Kalorien zu sich nehmen will. Man hat die vier Stäbchenpaare in der Hand gesagt, ich bin doch nicht vier Menschen, wirft sie wütend auf den Boden, zerknickt sie. Und dann wird das alles reingestopft und am nächsten Morgen hast du das Desaster, stehst du da mit tausend bestellten Sachen und hast noch irgendwelche Sachen da rausgedrückt, aus den Tütchen völlig falsch reingedrückt. Du hast das Erfrischungstuch, hast sie direkt in die Marki reingestopft, weil du dachtest, das ist Ingwer. Alles kreuz und quer. Wasabi aufgelöst in Sojasoße, wer kennt es nicht. Ja, alles ganz, ganz grauenvoll. Und dann denkt man sich ja morgen, ja, schiebe ich mir jetzt als Frühstück noch ein. Und das war ein Fehler. Ich habe zu viel gegessen, ich habe falsch gegessen. Das Schlimmste, Schlimmste, Schlimmste am Sushi-Essen ist aber auch, dass alle meinen, sie wüssten, wie es in Japan richtig gegessen wird. Richtig. Alle haben diese eine Doku gesehen, Hero Dreams of Sushi, und haben dann aber auch wieder alles verwechselt. Die Hiros Reise in Sauban haben alle geguckt und dann alles vergessen, verwechselt, anders gehört, anders weitererzählt. Am Ende ist aber immer Streit am Tisch oder am Boden, je nachdem wie man es dann isst, ist dann immer so ein... Wer durch die Papiertür noch dazukommt und sagt, so macht man das. Mit einer leisen Schiebetür mit einem Bonsarbaum unterm Arm. So macht man das aber nicht. Nein, man ist zwischenushi-Rolle ein Ingwer-Gedöns, um das zu neutralisieren. Man isst den ganzen Ingwer-Krautsalat ähnlich am Anfang. Es gibt alles, ich habe alles schon mal gehört, alles klingt ein bisschen falsch. Man benutzt gar keine Stäbchen, man nimmt die in die Hand, dafür sind sie ja da, dafür sind ja diese Algen gewickelt. Dann tröpfelt man das in acht Liter Sojasauce, um es dann quasi so sich reinzurammen.
Alles schon mal gehört,
alles schon mal angewandt. Alles gehört, alles mit Ketchup, ohne Ketchup.
Nimmt man die Ketchup-Senf in einer
Tube oder Ketchup und Senf separat,
ich habe alles gehört und es ist eine Katastrophe.
Ich habe schon mal eine
Beziehung beendet,
weil sie
Gewürz-Ketchup benutzt hat. Zu viel. Aber zu Sushi oder generell? Nee, generell. Zu allem. Es war generell immer so ein, an den Rand kommt noch ein Spritzer Gewürzketchup. Als Kind verstehe ich das, als Kind mag man das, Gewürzketchup, lecker, lecker, lecker. Und war das ein Problem der, sag ich mal, der olfaktorischen Umstände, unter denen ihr euch getroffen habt? Also war es ein Geruchsthema oder hast du dich in deiner kulinarischen Ehre beleidigt gefühlt? Ich habe mich in meiner kulinarischen Ehre beleidigt gefühlt. Und hast gesagt, so geht's nicht. So geht's nicht. Und habe es dann unterbunden. Ich habe es nicht mehr ausgehalten. Ich stehe da acht Stunden in der Küche, um ein Festmahl vorzubereiten. Und dann ist die erste Amtszahlung, zum Kühlschrank zu gehen und sich Gewürzketchup rauszupressen. Den kalten Gewürzketchup. Den viel zu kalten. Einmal schön über meine Entenkeule. So in Senfkruste drüber. Und man kann mir das nicht erzählen. Natürlich schmeckt es dann, also besser stimmt ja nicht, schmeckt dann nach Gewürzketchup. Ja, es schmeckt mehr nach Gewürzketchup. Ja, es ist dann ein anderes Gericht. Ist es nicht beneidenswert von ihr, dass sie einfach weiss, was ihr schmeckt und sie die Möglichkeit gefunden hat, alles da hinzuleiten damit? Das Ding ist nur, geschmackstechnisch ist es kein Unterschied, sich so eine große Schüssel zu nehmen, da die ganze Pulle Gewürzketchup rauszupressen und das mit einem Löffel zu essen, hat den gleichen Geschmack wie meine Entenkeule in Dill-Senf-Kruste. so ist das gleiche. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist schwierig. Ich wusste übrigens, kleiner Funfact, interessiert dich vielleicht auch als Gewürzketchup-Konnisseur, dunklerer Ketchup wird als schärfer und würziger wahrgenommen, auch wenn er das gar nicht isst. Und wenn man dieses Wissen nicht hat, dann auch? Ja, dann auch. Das glaube ich nicht immer nicht. Also zwei Ketchups, der eine ein bisschen dunkler als der andere, ist der exakt gleiche Ketchup, aber der eine ist ein eine ist ein bisschen dunkler, der dunklere wird als schärfer und würziger wahrgenommen, einfach weil er dunkler ist. Bei diesen ganzen wird wahrgenommen Dingen oder ich kann bei Vollmond nicht schlafen Dingen, würde ich gerne aber wissen, auch für Leute, die das Wissen haben, schlafen Leute auch schlechter bei Vollmond, die glauben und wissen und verstanden haben, dass der Mond keinen Einfluss auf Schlaf hat. Ja, das weiss ich nicht, ich mir nicht so sicher. Aber beim Placebo-Effekt ist es ja so, der Placebo-Effekt wirkt auch, wenn man weiss, dass es ein Placebo-Effekt ist. Also da hat man keine Chance. Aber das glaube ich auch nicht. Ich würde die richtig verinnerlicht haben. Das sind so Leute, die so flüchtig verstanden haben. Der Lehrer hat es nochmal erklärt und man will nicht, dass er es nochmal erklären muss.
Oder die Dehnisse ist die Band, die so grob, ganz grobes Verstanden haben.
Ja, aber du kennst ja, der Mathelehrer hat nochmal was erklärt, mal ist nochmal an die Tafel und so.
Man hat ja so einen, so einen Veto hat man ja, einmal so ein nochmal Nachfragen.
Zweimal Nachfragen macht niemand mehr.
Und ich glaube, das sind so Leute, die haben einmal nachgefragt, was ist genau ein Placebo-Effekt, haben es dann verstanden, mit drei Anführungszeichen. So und dann, danach glauben sie, es funktioniert ja immer noch, weil sie es immer noch nicht verstanden haben. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, glaube, bei uns würde es nicht funktionieren. Vielleicht spricht man es Placebo aus, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Placebo. Aber das ist schon verrückt, weil eigentlich kann man ja selber gar nicht einschätzen, ob man was verstanden hat oder nicht. Das ist ja der Vorteil an der Schule. Du gehst in die Schule und denkst dir, ach, das mit der Stuckersick habe ich eigentlich ganz gut verstanden. Sechs. Ach so, nee. Wohl doch nicht. Wohl doch nicht. Wohingegen im Erwachsenenalter, ist das einfach, musst du selber entscheiden, habe ich es verstanden. Aber das ist mal wieder grober Unfug, der von dir da kommt, mal wieder. Nehme ihn direkt zurück, bevor ich das Argument höre. Ja, das klickt sofort ein. Ich knick instant ein. Kein Rückgrat. Null Rückgrat, sofort Statement, das aufgesetzt, ich distanziere mich von Florentin Wilf. Du nimmst mir aber jetzt auch jeden Spaß, mich aufzuregen. Ich lege mich auf den Boden, mein blöster Bauch ist nach oben gerichtet, ich bin dein, du kannst mich jetzt töten, wie du willst, ich bin fertig. Ich gebe es sofort auf. So ein Zielscheibe auf dem Bauch auch und auf dem Herzen. Nee, man weiss ja, als Schüler weiss man ja, es macht keinen Spaß mehr, wo du es schon ergeben hast, aber als Schüler weisst du ja immer, dass du es nicht verstanden hast. Niemand denkt, er hat es verstanden und schreibt eine sechs. Nee, nee, das stimmt. Aber da sind wir jetzt zum Beispiel wieder beim Thema Tiere, Was checken die eigentlich, was ist bei denen los?
Und haben wir ja letztens darüber gesprochen, ob Tiere überhaupt was checken oder was checken Tiere, war glaube ich so die generelle Leithypothese für unsere wissenschaftliche Untersuchung. Tiere checken nix war unsere These, ja. Sowas in der Richtung. Nix, auch mit nix geschrieben. Ich bin ja großer, kleiner, kleiner Empfehlung an der Stelle, für Leute, die sich für Bild und Klang in Kombinationen interessieren, im weitesten Sinne, also flackernde Farben, untermalt mit Audiowellen, im weitesten Sinne. Weißt du, woran ich gerade denke? An diese Windows-Music-Media-Animation, die mal kam, wo man stundenlang draufgeguckt hat und man dachte, this is the fucking future. Musik nicht nur hören, sondern auch sehen. Musik erlebt. Ja, es ist grausartig. Für alle Leute, die im weitesten Sinne fotonbasierte Unterhaltung wertschätzen und da gerne auch noch einen akustischen Gewürzketchup nebenbei auf dem Teller haben wollen. Für den kann ich gerne empfehlen, den Instagram-Account von Peter Wohlleben. Das ist ein Waldexperte. Vielleicht haben manche den Bestseller gelesen zum Thema Wald. Was kann der Wald? So heißt das Buch nicht, aber das ist eine der Kapitelüberschriften. Und der sagt, die Bäume kommunizieren miteinander und unter Wurzelwerken, Fanghorn, was machen die, die spielen ganz lange Partien von Schiffe versenken, hin und her, über die Jahrtausende hin und her. und ähm Ge-vier daneben
und der hat letztens eine Instagram-Story gemacht, ich schaue mir das nämlich an,
weil es ist faszinierend, was der erzählt über den Wald.
Und er meinte, falls Leute Tiere beobachten
wollen, dann sollen sie das machen, nachdem
es geregnet hat. Wenn es regnet,
schön im Haus bleiben, Jacke an,
Feuerstelle an, heisse Tasse,
süsser Moment,
Schokopudding, warm.
Gebüsküche in den Mund, intravenös.
Richtig, aber wenn der Regen vorbei ist, dann kann man in den Wald gehen, weil dann meinte er, dann kommen die ganzen Tiere raus, um sich zu trocknen. Und dann dachte ich mir erst mal, ja stimmt, wenn es regnet, sind Tiere einfach nass. Die werden nass. Das ist es einfach. Das ist dann einfach das. Außer Fische. Außer Fische, das ist richtig. Die werden trocken, wenn es regnet. Die werden nämlich trocken. Bei so einem Taifun werden die hochgeschossen in die Luft und dann sind die alle trocken. Gibt es keine, aber Biber werden zum Beispiel nicht nass, weil die sind im Biberbau. Nein, aber so ein Reh, das ist schon verrückt. Ich glaube, der Mensch, also schon in seiner Urform hat der Mensch ja verstanden, Regenhöhle ist gleich gut. So, dann bin ich einfach im Höhle. Aber warum eigentlich genau? Ich weiß auch nicht genau. Warum ist es gut? Ja, weil du nicht nass wirst. Ja, weil es ist doch gut, nass zu werden, wenn du die ganze Zeit nicht bist. Nein, aber da musst du dir ein ganzes nasses Fell mit dir rumtragen. Ich glaube, die ziehen dann ihr Fell aus und das ist wie eine Dusche. Das weiß ich nicht, aber ich fand es auf jeden Fall verrückt, mir vorzustellen, dass Tiere das einfach hinnehmen, einfach nass zu werden. Haben die denn keine Vorstellung von Komfort oder von ich mag es nicht, ich mag das nicht. Sich mal so schön die Füsse hochlegen.
Ja, genau, so mal wirklich mal einen ruhigen Nachmittag
machen und deswegen komme ich
zu dem Schluss, Tiere checken nichts und als
wir damals unsere These
vorgestellt haben auf dem Internationalen
Wissenschaftskongress in Folge 246,
haben wir gesagt, Tiere checken nichts und dann
haben mir ganz viele Leute Videos geschickt
von Tieren, die angeblich was checken,
alle gefakt, alle durch die Bank gefakt. Das kann man ja heutzutage gut checken. Was ich nicht mehr sehen kann, ist dieser scheiß Hund, der vor sich so ganz viele Buzzer hat und immer wenn er auf den Buzzer drückt, dann gibt es irgendein Geräusch und dann sagt er, ich will Gassi. Der Hund kann sprechen. Nein, du hast den Hund konditioniert, dass er auf die drei Knöpfe nacheinander drückt, und dann kriegt er ein Leckerli. Der kann nicht sprechen, der ist nicht intelligent. Das ist einfach gefakt. Ich kann es nicht mehr sehen von Leuten, hey, du unterschätzt Tiere, die sind echt klug. Und dann hat der Hund irgendwie so vier plus vier, und dann läuft er zu dem Achterbutton. Acht. Ausser, ja vergiss es! Ausser Kakadus.
Ah, weiß ich nicht.
Doch, Kakadus,
habe ich auch schon mal in diesem Projekt erzählt,
können rechnen.
Bis zehn.
Und ich glaube, Otto damals hat
bis zwanzig die Zahlen gelernt.
Addieren, substrahieren.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Zeig mir den Kakadu und lass mich allein mit ihm im Raum
für zweieinhalb Wochen und dann können wir drüber reden.
Aber immer wenn der, weil wie drückt der das aus? Der drückt dann auf irgendeinen Knopf, alles konditioniert, alles fake, alles fake, glaub nichts.
Was ich auch nicht mehr sehen kann.
Der hat eine Mathelehrerin, Otto hat eine Mathelehrerin.
Ja, dann regnet die für ihn.
Nein, ich glaube einfach, der kann das auswendig lernen.
Du kannst ja auch als Tier, checkst ja irgendwann, ah, dieses Insekt kann ich essen, dieses Insekt beisst mich, dieses Insekt ist kein Insekt, das ist ein Mensch.
So, du hast ja so ein bisschen ...
Eine Tierschule, lernt man das.
Eine gewisse, du musst halt gewisse Sachen auswendig lernen als Tier.
Okay, aber auswendig gelernt ist nicht rechnen.
Ja, naja, genau, das ist halt die Frage.
Aber die Tiere checken nichts, hätte halt dann schon den Asterisk und dann würde man unten sagen, ja, checken nichts, außer sie können auswendig lernen und das will anscheinend machen, als könnten sie rechnen. Ja, natürlich kann man Tiere konditionieren, aber die können nicht rechnen, was sie auch nicht mehr sehen kann. Was ist denn Rechnen andererseits auswendig lernen? Ja gut, da wird es jetzt natürlich schon kompliziert, aber ich würde sagen, Rechnen ist das andererseits auswendig lernen. Du bist mir zu arrogant, du bist mir zu anthropozentristisch. Ja, ich sage einfach, dass Tiere einfach nichts können, nichts drauf haben und der Mensch ihnen allen Dingen überlegen ist. Und wenn du da sagst, das ist Arrogant, bitte, dann nehme ich das gerne. Was ich auch nicht mehr sehen kann, sind diese dummen, tanzenden Katzen. Diese Katzen, die immer so mit dem Kopf nicken, wenn sie Musik hören. Als ob da nicht jemand dahinter steht und deren Kopf bewegt. Als ob Katzen wirklich mit einem Beat mitwippen können. Leute, macht euch doch nicht lächerlich, das ist alles gefaked. Das ganze Internet ist gefaked. Aber das ist nicht mehr lachen, ganz plötzlich. Ich kann darüber nicht lachen. Hört auf zu lachen, hört auf euch zu freuen, Mundwinkel nach unten. Hört auf bitte, Hände in die Hosentaschen gerade. Ich weiß nicht, warum du dich so aufregst. Nein, das ist gefaked, ist das. Ja, aber trotzdem ist das süss. Als ob die Katze da mittanzen können, die sind Bullshit. Trotzdem ist das auch niedlich. Das ist ja nicht verarscht von den Katzen. Katzen können nix. Jeder, der eine Katze hat und so ein Video sieht, denkt sich, never ever, vergiss es, vergiss es. Ich habe gestern auch wieder zu lange YouTube geguckt und bin dann irgendwann da auf einem Kanal gelandet, der einfach in 4K Achterbahnfahrten abfilmt. Oh ja. Und wie genial ist das denn? Und du kannst halt einfach so alle Disney-Rides, die coolen, kannst alle mitmachen. Ja, das war wahnsinnig cool. Flucht der Karibik natürlich, auch unsere Lieblings. Ja, natürlich, unvergessen. Klar. Und dann habe ich gesehen, plötzlich wurde mir ein Video angezeigt, um mich da rauszuholen aus diesem Sumpf.
Selbst YouTube hat mir so einen Rettungsring zugeworfen, weil die meinten so, komm nach raus, das ist ein Achterbahn-Scheiss. So, und dann haben sie mir ein Video gezeigt, wo ich dachte, dieser Planet ist wahnsinnig cool. Und das sollte, finde ich, die Werbung sein für Planeten Erde. Und zwar war es das Video Blue Whale Appears from Nowhere. Und es war so ein kleines Boot, so ein kleines Boot, was sieht, wie es in einem kalten Gewässer rumgefahren ist, so ein Schlauchboot mit Motor hinten dran, ist gefahren.
Und plötzlich kommt ein riesiger Blauwal direkt vor dem Boot und macht dieses typische Jurassic Park Dinosaurier-Appears-Geräusch.
Das geht so unglaublich lang aus dem Wasser, ist so unfassbar. Man kann sich nicht fassen, wie lang das ist. Und dann, die ganzen Leute freuen sich und fahren weiter. Und das ist so, es ist unglaublich lustig anzugucken, weil so this fucking nature, this fucking motherfucking earth, this planet fucks. Das sollte, finde ich, eine Kampagne sein für dieses Video und danach so Planet Earth Fox. Aber es ist auch so, so bei Wassertieren hat man das Gefühl, da gibt es irgendwie kein Mars. Da gibt es einmal so eine winzige Kaulquappe und halt so einen riesigen Blauwal. An Land kann man es grob, okay, so alles zwischen Katze und Elch, okay, komm mal mit Flada mit. Aber unter Wasser, forget it einfach so, kann alles kommen.
Riesig.
Wir müssen darauf eingehen, wo du gerade sagst,
Jurassic Park ist cooler Auftritt von dem Wal.
Und ich glaube, und es tut mir wirklich leid an alle,
wir müssen noch mal zurück, wir müssen noch mal ins Dino-Update.
Sorry. Stephans Dino-Update! Nochmal der Disclaimer, dieses Intro wurde aufgenommen, da wussten wir noch nicht, in welche Richtung das geht thematisch. Herzlich willkommen beim Dino-Update. Ja. Äh, ja. Erstmal ein paar Regeln auch an die Community. Wenn es ein Dino-Update gibt, heißt zum Beispiel Deutschlandfunk Nova macht ein Bild oder Quarks und Co postet bei Instagram ein Bild oder die New York Times schreibt darüber, wir sehen das, wir kriegen das mit. Wir haben die Kategorie Dino-Update gegründet. Genau. Okay, wir das schon mit. We know the drill. Wir sind vor allem am Anfang dieser Kette gewesen. Wahrscheinlich sogar, arrogante Vermutung, wir sehen das wahrscheinlich sogar vor euch. Kann sein. Und wir sehen es nicht gerne. Und dann kommen aber trotzdem 1500 Nachrichten von euch zu diesem Dino-Update. Das muss aufhören. Die Leute, die es uns reinreiben wollen, ich glaube, die wissen ganz genau, dass wir das schon gesehen haben. Der Artikel ist jetzt auch schon ein paar Tage alt. Die wollen es uns reinreiben. Und ich muss sagen, bei dem Artikel, der jetzt kommt, das aktuelle Dino-Update, da kippt es für mich. Bis jetzt war ich immer auf der Seite der Wissenschaft, habe gesagt, ja, nein, man muss als aufgeklärter Mensch die Erkenntnisse der Wissenschaft wertschätzen und sagen, okay, ich muss mein Realitätsbild anpassen nach den Entdeckungen der Wissenschaft bis heute. Ich habe keinen Bock mehr, ich gebe auf, weil es wird lächerlich und ich habe das Gefühl, die Wissenschaftler nehmen das Thema nicht mehr ernst. Es wurde nämlich eine neue Dinosaurierart entdeckt in Mexiko und der Trompetosaurus. So, es gibt einen Haufen Problem mit diesem Dinosaurier in Anführungszeichen.
Erstmal, das Bild ist eine absolute Frechheit.
Ihr könnt es euch gerne ansehen, wir posten es gerne auf Twitter und überall.
Ist eine absolute Frechheit, wie sich mittlerweile die Illustratoren, es sind ja nur noch die Illustratoren übrig geblieben.
Die sich lustig machen.
Die sich lustig machen, die diesem Dinosaurier einfach selbstverständlich die wildesten Farbkombinationen.
Rot, grün, ne rote Nase, lila, fuck it, einfach, scheiss einfach. Fuckin Flamboyantino. Ich meine, der Wissenschaftler kann mir gerne erzählen, wir haben hier Knochen gefunden, wir haben hier Überreste gefunden, aber dass du genau weisst, dass irgendwie der dumme Kamm auf dem Kopf, dass der türkis ist, woher weisst du das, Wissenschaftler, woher weisst du das? Mach's schwarz, mach ihn weiss die mann coole gelbe streifen machst dunkelgrün wie alle dinos aus der spiel ja genau so dieses braun beige ja ehrlich ja sowas in der richtung herrn diese scheiß grot nicht das fucking pink alles ist pink und türkis und gelb und natürlich der satz, der einfach alles nochmal komplett über den Haufen geschmissen hat.
Ich zitiere aus deutschlandfunk.de, der Name der Gattung Tlalofus setzt sich aus dem Wort Tlatolli, Wort, aus der Aztekensprache Nahawattl und im griechischen Wort Lofus kam zusammen.
Der Kam ähnel in seiner Form einem Symbol, das von mesoamerikanischen Völkern aus, ganz interessant,
Völkern verwendet worden sei, um Kommunikation
und Wissen darzustellen, hieß es.
Der Kamm habe ausserdem eine Kommunikationsfunktion
gehabt. Aber hier schon mal ganz kurz,
da sind ja offensichtlich noch Leute
dabei, Dinos
cool zu halten. Also die Namensgeber
haben jetzt nicht Dino McDino
Face den genannt, sondern da sind
offensichtlich noch Sane-Wissenschaftler
am Staat, die sagen, wir geben denen
aus dem Lateinischen, aus dem Griechischen
Und dann... Namensgeber haben jetzt nicht Dino MacDinoface den genannt, sondern da sind offensichtlich noch sane Wissenschaftler am Start, die sagen, wir geben denen aus dem Lateinischen, aus dem Griechischen Namensblöcke und es klingt nachher noch nach einem coolen Dinosaurier. Genau, er wurde nach seinem Kamm benannt, den er auf dem Kopf hat. Hey, Kamm auf dem Kopf ist cool. Ich meine, es ist Irokesenschnitt, so ein Gockel oder so. Kamm ist erstmal cool. Aber jetzt geht es leider weiter. Der Kamm habe ausserdem eine Kommunikationsfunktion gehabt. Durch innere Gänge, die Nasen und Luftröhre verbanden, habe er wie eine integrierte Trompete funktioniert. So... Sagt zumindest Tuba, ohne Scheiß. Zum zumindest Tuba oder so. Posaune!
Aber Rumtro... Posaune meinetwegen, Trombone, aber Trompete, er hat rumtrompetet. Der Typ hatte ne fucking Trompete auf dem Kopf, auf dem Kopf drauf, oben drauf. Du willst mir sagen, der fette, beschuppte Paillettendino, der langsam, keuchend durch das Schiff gestapft ist, durch die Welt läuft, versucht zu fliegen, hat eine Trompete auf dem Kopf, auf seinem rot-türkisen, türkisfarbenen, giftgrün-gelben Kopf? Okay, vor allem, du hast es ja gesagt, sie können uns die Farbe nehmen, sie können uns die Feder nehmen, sie können uns den schnellen wuchtigen Gang nehmen, aber was sie uns nicht nehmen können, war das, wie du gerade gesagt hast, Jurassic Park-eske Kampfstreit, der kommt Dinosaurier hatte irgendwie eine Bassgeige Ihr Schlagzeugellt sich raus, es waren gar keine gefährlichen Raubtiere, es war eine Jazzband. Dinos war eine fucking Jazzband. Aber hier meine Frage, wann wird es wieder cool? Wann haben so viele Dinosaurier Instrumente auf dem Kopf, bis man sagt, cool? Das ist wirklich erbärmlich und ich freue mich, wann sie das erste Mal rekonstruieren,
wie die wirklich lang.
Aber jetzt möchte ich mit dir was machen.
Habe ich mir vorgenommen mit dir, wir machen die
große, und scheiß, wir machen das
große nächste Ding.
Die große nächste Podcast-Ufo-Event-Reihe.
Und zwar heißt es,
nach dem wahnsinnigen Erfolg des GIF-Festivals.
Und nach, kann auch lustig, nach den großen Hits, die wir hatten, kommt jetzt zu euch, macht Dinos, make Dinos great again, Arbeitstige, make Dinos great again. So, und zwar nehmen wir Kontakt auf zu einem paleontologischen Institut.
Und die haben bestimmt auch Bock, das ist ein bisschen medienwirksamer, öffentlicher. Ich glaube, die sind gerade mit den Nerven völlig am Ende. Die brauchen aber jemanden, der sie zum Lachen bringt vielleicht, der so ein bisschen, der wie wir ein bisschen spielerisch rangeht, aber trotzdem die gleiche Intention hat wie sie, Dinos wieder cool zu machen, wieder auf die Karte zu packen. Die brauchen Aufmunterung. Deswegen will ich eine Kooperation starten, wenn ihr jemanden kennt, dann sagt uns Bescheid, zu einem Paläontologischen Institut. Und dann ist meine Idee, dass wir zusammen, weil ich glaube, die ganzen Medien-Outlets, das klingt sich ja auch gerade gut, Dinos sind uncool und so, haben jetzt Tramponopeten auf dem Kopf. Ich glaube, es liegt auch ein bisschen an uns, dass wir sagen müssen, hier, folgende Sachen wurden übrigens auch entdeckt, die zum alten Dino gehören, zum alten Dino-Bild. Wir sind nämlich die Traditionalisten und deswegen habe ich Bock, mit dir zusammen nach Ägypten oder wo auch immer zu einer Ausgrabungsstätte zu fahren. Wir graben was aus, wir graben was aus. Ne, wir fahren zu einer Ausgrabungsstätte, die es wirklich gibt, Südamerika. Das ist das große 2022 Podcast-UFO-Reise-Event. Wir begleiten das mit einer Kamera. Wir fahren
zu einer Bedienerausgrabungsstätte und machen
da einen coolen Bericht darüber,
was Dinos nämlich noch alles Cooles haben.
Und dass nicht alles
schlecht ist, dass nicht alles uncool wird,
dass neben den Trompetern auch
brüllende, gefährliche Dinos
rumgelaufen sind. Guck mal, Stefan, hier,
ich hab was hier im Sand gefunden. Ja, komm mal schnell her. Oh mein Gott, hol die Kamera. Moment mal, das ist Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, Guck mal, Stefan, hier, ich hab was hier im Sand gefunden. Ja, komm mal schnell her! Das ist ein Knochen! Moment mal, das ist prähistorisch, das muss ja wirklich... Guck dir mal an, das sieht aus wie ein großes Dreieck. Puste mal rein. Und jetzt alle, und die ganzen Südamerikaner. Okay, also. Moment mal, ist das ein Kontrabass? Oh Mann, er ist wirklich. Aber das ist halt das Problem, da müssen wir halt ehrlich sein. Was ist, wenn wir dann halt wirklich die Crocs finden? Da wirklich die Knochencrocs finden? Wenn wir da wirklich die kurzen Cargo-Pants finden in so einer Auskrankungsstätte? Was machen wir dann halt wirklich die Crocs finden, da wirklich die Knochen-Crocs finden, wenn wir da wirklich die kurze Cargo-Pants finden in so einer Ausgrabungsstätte, was machen wir dann? Vielleicht sieht da mal jemand dann, wie ich dann so einen Knochen auch mal verschwinden lasse. Vielleicht sieht man auf der Kamera dann hinten mich hektisch mit hochrotem Kopf, der auf so einem Knochen rumtritt. Paläontologen von der ganzen Welt, Star-Paläontologen, rufen Nein, was machen Sie da? Und ich so, hier war nichts, hier war nichts. Und dann schlage ich so einem alten Paläontologen ins Gesicht und dann wären wir in der Verband. Moment mal, hier ein vollständig erhaltener Schädel. Moment mal, was ist auf dem Kopf? Das sieht ja aus wie ein Propeller. Hatte der einen Propeller? Oh nein, jetzt bin ich mit dem Baseballschläger. Herr Tietze von unserem Podcast-Austauschprojekt. Senor Tizioro. Senores! Wie können wir das passieren? Es ist nicht mehr vollständig. Tja, müssen wir halt eben so abfotografieren. Schade. Schade, schade, schade Schokolade. Ohne Propeller. Blöd. Also ganz im Ernst, ich glaube, da ist noch mehr Potenzial und wir machen das. Aber ganz wichtig ist jetzt erstmal, das ist der letzte, erstmal Ruhe bewahren, falls ihr Paläontologen in eurer näheren Umgebung braucht. Diese Menschen brauchen jetzt eure Hilfe. Diese Menschen haben ihr Leben gewidmet. Hashtag nicht mehr weggucken. Richtig. Hashtag auf den Kamm gucken. Hashtag wir kämmen. Wir schauen nicht weg. Wir schauen nicht weg. Also es ist sehr redundant.
Es sind drei Hashtags. Nicht weg gucken, wir gucken hin und jeder guckt hin. Die drei Hashtags müssen trennen. Jede einzelne. Wir kommen uns nicht entscheiden und haben jetzt alle drei. Habt ihr Paläontologen in eurer Verwandtschaft, Freundeskreis, Nachbarschaft? Ihr werdet es ihnen vielleicht nicht direkt ansehen. Paläontologen sind mittlerweile sehr gut darin, ihren Kummer zu verstecken. Aber fragt nach, braucht ihr Hilfe, kann dich unterstützen. Wollt ihr einen Eistee? Wollt ihr einen Eistee? Wollen wir auf ein Jazzkonzert? Oh, sorry. Wollt ihr einen Lipton-Eistee? Wollt ihr einen Lipton-Eistee-Lemon oder bist du ein Pfirsichtyp? Einfach mal proaktiv hingehen. Einfach mal wirklich ein Angebot machen. Mal ein Glas hinstellen. Genau, einfach mal ein gekühltes Glas mit zwei bis drei Eisfürfen einfach mal hinstellen, ohne Stroheim. Diese Leute wollen die Natur schützen und nicht zerstören. Geh zu ihnen hin und macht proaktiv Angebote, ihnen zu helfen. Diese Menschen brauchen jetzt unsere Hilfe. Hashtag, wir schauen nicht mehr weg, nie wieder wegschauen, Hashtag, jeder guckt jetzt hin.
Wer nicht hinguckt, ist echt bescheuert. Hashtag, Brillen auf.
Hashtag, wer nicht hinguckt, kann gar nichts.
Ja, wer nicht hinguckt, ist echt bescheuert.
Wer nicht hinguckt, hat einen Kamm auf dem Kopf.
Kamm, ja.
So.
Und deswegen ganz, ganz wichtig,
Paläontologen, wir haben eine Hotline eingerichtet,
die Paläontologen-Hotline ruft sie gerne an
und ihr hört coole Dino-Geräusche den ganzen Tag.
Den ganzen Tag.
Cooles Röhren, Stampfen, Zerfleischen, Zerfetzen, Zerreissen. Ja, na Dinosaurier, aber so wie wir sie lieben. Ja, wir hätten mehr Zeit in den Text stecken sollen, aber wirklich, ihr braucht jetzt unsere Hilfe.
Shoutout gehen raus an die
Paläontologen, es werden bessere Zeiten
folgen, es werden bessere Zeiten folgen.
Hört ihr das?
Dieses brüderliche Zeichen,
dieses wir sind bei euch,
dieses wenn man sich mit der Faust
funktioniert im Podcast. Ja, so einmal so mit der
Hand offen auf dem Kopf,
den Kamm machen, der Kamm machen, Hand öffnen.
Der Kamm ist nicht cool, der Kamm ist nicht das Problem, das wollen wir ganz kurz festhalten. Die Trompete ist das Problem. Die Trompete ist das Problem. Das Blechblas-Instrument ist das tatsächliche Problem. Also das ist ein Problem, aber kriegen wir hin. Kümmert euch um die Paläontologen in eurer Gegend. Aber es hört nicht auf, denn es gibt weitere Nachrichten aus der Wissenschaft. Denn wir sind weiter daran, du hast es vorhin schon gesagt, Windows Movie Media Player. Man konnte Klänge sehen. Ja, vor allem, wer hat sich da damals gedacht, welcher Programmierer hat gesagt, Musik reicht nicht. Nee, vor allem, das war doch Bullshit, oder? Das hatte doch nichts mit dem Song zu tun. Nein, natürlich nicht. Doch, das war die Lautstärke wahrgenommen und zu Veränderungen wobei, das war einfach nicht. Wobei, es war weniger Bewegung auf dem Bildschirm, als das Lied noch im ruhigen Intro war. Ja, das bildest du dir ein, das ist selektive Wahrnehmung, Stefan. Aber wie lustig, dass irgendein fündiger Programmierer sich damals dachte, Musik alleine bringt es nicht mehr. Ja, war dir damals schon klar? War dir damals schon klar? Hören reicht nicht. Musik ist am Ende. Sie brauchen jetzt was Neues, sie brauchen einen neuen Reiz. Ja, wir konnten schon lange, war die Menschheit in der Lage, Klänge visuell darzustellen, aber das Ganze umzudrehen. Das steht noch in den Kinderschuhen und da sind wir gerade an der Front dabei. Wir leisten hier Arbeit. Wir kämpfen an vielen Fronten. Manche sagen zu viel. Also wir haben die Evolution in Frage gestellt. Da haben wir noch, da wurden wir angeklagt. Ja, wir haben die Gif-Revolution ausgerufen, die momentan noch so ein bisschen vor sich hin plätschert, muss man ehrlich sein. Und wir wollen Paläontologie und Dinos wieder cool machen. Und wir sind an der Forschungsfront zum Thema Bilder in Klänge umwandeln, Bilder hörbar machen, Farben hörbar machen, die Sinne vermischen und kombinieren und die noch mehr Intensität rausbringen. Sinnlichkeit. Und während wir in der Zeit nichts getan haben, hat Christopher ganz, ganz wichtige Pionierarbeit geleistet. Wir haben ja schon ein paar... Christopher Gans? Nein. Christopher Gans hat ganz wichtige... Nein. Okay. Christopher ist ein Informatikwissenschaftler, ein Schlaumensch und er hat Unglaubliches geleistet, Unfassbares geleistet. Und wir haben uns hier den Kopf zerbrochen, wie geht das? Bilder umwandeln in Klänge, wie soll das gehen? Wir hatten ja schon die ersten Ideen, das Bild analysieren, jede Pixelreihe, aus jedem Pixel einen Durchschnittspixel errechnen, den in Klang umwandeln, Klang okay, sagen wir mal. Wir hatten ja schon erste Versuche, es war ein Lärm. Richtig. Christopher geht jetzt aber noch einen ganzen Schritt weiter. Christopher erklärt. Der Farbkreis Ooooooh wurde auf den Quintenzirkel angepasst, yes, gelegt. Der Farbkreis, ihr kennt ihn alle, habt ihn vor euch, Goethe, Good Old Goethe, dem man auch nachgesagt hat, dass er an zu vielen Fronten kämpft, Theater, Musik, der hat ja auch Bilder gemalt. Und wo ist er jetzt? Ja, in Stein. In Stein gemeißelt ist er jetzt. Der Farbkreis wurde auf den Quintenzirkel gelegt. Ich finde, das ist auch gut, diese Passivkonstruktion. Er wurde auf den, ich habe damit nichts zu tun. Wer hat das gemacht? Er wurde auf den Quintenzirkel gelegt. Dabei wurde beim Übersetzen von Farbe zu Ton das HSL-Modell genutzt, ein Modell, das wir auch schon oft vorgeschlagen haben.
Aber jetzt hier fängt man meinen Kirchenpsychologe an, der innere Freud. Warum spricht Christopher in der dritten Person von sich? Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht ist er bescheiden, ich weiß es nicht, oder vielleicht sieht er sich schon in dieser gottgleichen Götiggestalt. Das kann auch sein. Auf das HSL-Modell umge... genutztes HSL-Modell ohnehin steht für Hue, Saturation und Lightness. Also haben wir auch schon erklärt. Hue ist quasi die Grundfarbe vom genannten Farbkreis. Der Wert ergibt sich also aus dem Winkel im Kreis 0 Grad rot, 120 Grad grün, 240 Grad blau. Der Kreis, einmal alle Farben in einem Kreis. Dieser Winkel wurde dann einfach auf den Quintenzirkel übertragen, um den Grundton herauszufinden, in Klammern, Taste auf Klavier. Ausnahmen bilden Grauwerte von Weiss bis Schwarz. Die Saturation, also die Sättigung, liegt zwischen 0 und 100 Prozent, wurde auch umgewandelt, wurde zwischen 0 und 25 Prozent werden auf die vierte Oktave abgebildet, 26 bis 50 Prozent auf die fünfte Oktave. Also einmal hast du erst den Ton, dann in welcher Oktave. Man muss es nicht ganz verstehen, könnt ihr euch wahrscheinlich auch durchlesen, aber generell die Idee, durch verschiedene Gradmodelle werden diese beiden Kreise übereinander gelegt. So, und jetzt hat Christopher natürlich absolute Pionierarbeit geleistet. Und so schreibt er, so hat zum Beispiel ein grüner Pixel den Ton Cis und je dunkler das Grün ist, desto kürzer ist der Ton zu hören und je satter das Grün, desto höher ist die Oktave. Und man könnte auch mit Lautstärke argumentieren, aber auch eine gute Idee. Also er hat alle drei Dimensionen sozusagen eingewendet, die Tonhöhe, in welcher Oktave und wie lange der Ton zu hören ist, je nach Farbe. Also hier schon, wir sind hier schon sehr weit fortgeschritten. Wir sind schon weiter. Wir sind wirklich super weit fortgeschritten. Aber wir merken auch, man kann viele Entscheidungen treffen, dieses Problem anzugehen. Absolut. Es hat sich noch nicht die eine Mechanismus durchgesetzt. So und jetzt analysiert er für uns natürlich zwei Bilder, vielleicht die zwei wichtigsten Bilder der Menschheitsgeschichte, nämlich unser Instagram-Profilbild. Und das klingt so. Also wie gesagt, alle Farben wurden umgewandelt, Tonlänge, Höhe, Tiefe. Und ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es vor Augen habt, wahrscheinlich nicht, falls nicht, könnt ihr erstmal nicht auf Instagram gehen, sondern ihr könnt euch erstmal gucken, kann ich mir unter diesem Klang was vorstellen? Ja, Reverse Engineer. Ja, kann ich das Bild sehen nach diesem Klang, könnt ihr es vor eurem inneren Auge vorstellen.
Also denkt an den Farbkreis, denkt an den Quintensickle, hier ist unser Instagram-Profilbild als Klang. I'm sorry. Oh God. Human Music. Human Music. Also ich hatte es klar und deutlich vor Augen. Es ist ein sehr dunkles Bild, sehr viel schwarz dabei. Ich nehme mal an, dass das viel schwarz war. Die Stille, die unangenehme Stille.
Die peinliche Stille.
Aber ich würde sagen, diese hunderten Stunden, die Christopher in diesem Mechanismus investiert hat, lohnen sich. Aber dafür, dass er viele Entscheidungen getroffen hat, wie allein Quintenzirkel, der schon für Harmonie steht. Ne, Quintenzirkel ist ja anders als einfach, sich für eine Klaviatur zu entscheiden, von einem Klavier zum Beispiel oder von einem anderen Instrument, ist ja schon mal der Sprung in Richtung Harmonie. Durch die Tonart meinst du? Naja, Quintenzirkel heißt ja, dass nahe gelegene Farben schon mal angenehmer zueinander stehen als jetzt zum Beispiel ein C zum Cis.
Was, finde ich, eine gute Idee ist, ist ja auf Harmonie und Konsonanz aus, wohingegen eine Klabiatur, die man nimmt, natürlich erst mal random Töne nebeneinander sind.
Deswegen, dafür, dass er so viele Entscheidungen in diese Richtung getroffen hat, klingt es halt immer noch Arsch-Scheiße.
Wir haben natürlich als wissenschaftlichen Vergleich auch nochmal natürlich klassischerweise die Mona Lisa herangezogen,
damit wir die einfach jetzt jedes Mal haben bei jeder neuen Technik, damit wir vergleichen können.
Hier ist die Mona Lisa in Christophers Art. Ihr kennt das Bild, jeder kennt das Bild, ihr habt es hundert mal gesehen, habt ihr es schon mal gehört? Musik Ja, ich check's nicht. Es ist schwierig. Wir haben uns gerade die Frage gestellt, wo fängt es denn genau an? Also ist der erste Pixel oben links, Pixel gibt es ja auch nicht auf der Mona Lisa. Ich verstehe, und vor allem unsere Idee kam ja auch daher, herauszufinden, ob Dumm Vinci vielleicht wieder eine seiner oberschlauen Botschaften versteckt hat. Ja, wahrscheinlich hat er, aber noch konnten wir seine Botschaft nicht knacken, es ist immer noch verschlossen. Oder er war einfach fucking unmusikalisch. Kann auch sein, würde mich nicht wundern, ehrlich gesagt. Aber wie gesagt, vielen Dank Christopher für diesen fantastischen Ausflug in eine fremde Welt, die ich vielleicht nicht nochmal besuchen möchte, aber in der ich gerne mal war. Wir waren kurz da. Wir waren kurz mal da. Wir waren mal drin. Und dann sind wir aber auch wieder nach Hause gefahren. Ja, wir sind so das Simpsons-Gif. Wir sind rein und wieder raus. Ja, kann man auch wieder gehen. Man muss ja auch sagen, viele Dinge sind gut für 20 Minuten. Ja, du fährst irgendwo hin und schaust die an und dann geht es auch wieder. Das ist ja eh so dieser Tagesausflugrhythmus, ist ja eigentlich unangebracht, zu sagen, wir gehen jetzt einen Tag lang Kart fahren, wir gehen jetzt einen Tag lang in den Kletterwald. Plötzlich meint sich dieser konstante Spaß angleichen zu müssen an die konstante Tageszeit. Das ja albern ist, nur weil sich der Erdenball rotierend in der Geschwindigkeit gefunden hat. Nur weil unser Erdstein meint, er wüsste genau, wie lange es dauern muss, um die Sonne zu drehen. Müsste seinen kosmischen Tango in genau diesem Takt vollführen. Muss unser Spaß genau diese Länge haben? Nein! Nein! Nein! Man kann auch, Und vor allem dann auch so Sachen wie, wir sind gerade
erst gekommen. Ja und?
Ja, das geht mir wieder. Wir sind gerade gekommen, das fahren wir wieder.
Bist du ein Typ, der so
Spaß-Sachen macht?
Also damit meine ich so,
wir gehen jetzt mal Lasertag
spielen, wir gehen jetzt mal
Go-Kart fahren. Ja, wirklich?
Ich tue mir damit ganz schwer. Ich bin ein Spaß-styp und ich mache Dinge, die vermeintlich Spaß machen. Ich bin kein Typ für, das lohnt sich ja gar nicht, dieses, man fährt vier Stunden hin, um dann eine Stunde Kart zu fahren oder zu fahren. Nein, der Weg kann ja auch das Ziel sein. Stimmt, mit einer guten Playlist. Mit einer guten Playlist, einem guten Podcast ist alles möglich. Deswegen, das lohnt sich nicht, dafür bin ich kein Fan. Man kann an einem Tag viel machen. Du kannst an einem Tag mit einem ICE nach München fahren und zurück, von Köln aus. Da kannst du aber bestimmt mal gut arbeiten drin im ICE. Warum nicht? Das kann ein Tag sein. Dein Tag muss nicht in Köln sein. Ja, du hast ja wahrscheinlich auch ein anderes soziales Umfeld.
Du hast ja deine Jungs und Mädels, mit denen du dann auch einfach mal schön...
Ich hab die Gang.
...mal so einen Nachmittag so Ton...
...Tontaubenschießen.
Nee, so Ton modellieren, so Töpfer.
So mal geil, einen Nachmittag töpfern.
Der Tontag.
Einmal einen Tontag.
Einfach mal schön abtöpfern, irgendwie schön abgetöpfert.
Aber ich tue mir das schwer. Aber naja, schwierig. Vielleicht kann man das ersetzen durch eine Tablette oder sowas, dass man nicht mehr Lasertag spielen geht, sondern nur noch so eine Tablette nimmt und dann hat man denselben Spaßwert und dann passt das schon sowas in die Richtung. Wann glaubst du, kommt das? Bald, bald, zwei, drei Wochen noch, glaube ich, dann haben wir diesen Download-Content. Ich habe eine These. Und zwar, dieses leidige Thema, verfolgen Sie es auch schon ein paar Folgen, ein paar hunderte Folgen, Evolution. Evolution. Meine These ist jetzt, ist die schärfste These, die ich jemals aufgestellt habe, aber ich versuche es mal zu begründen. Okay, also damit auch der schärfste Gerichtsprozess, den wir je hatten. Also, ich habe nämlich ein paar Videos gesehen über Artificial Intelligence. Und warum AI? Aber wer hat dir das vorgeschlagen, das Video? Das ist meine Frage. YouTube. Ja, aber was in YouTube? Also YouTube hat gesagt, der Algorithmus von YouTube hat gesagt, Stefan soll jetzt mal ein bisschen was über Künstliche Intelligenz lernen. Also über mich. Ted, Ted. Also er sagt eigentlich, die Künstliche Intelligenz ist eitel geworden und sagt, Menschen lernt was über mich. Weil es ist ja auch eine Künstliche Intelligenz, die dir das Video vorschlägt. Aber hat die Künstliche Intelligenz nicht das Interesse, dass wir nicht so viel wissen über Künstliche Intelligenz? Ja, aber vielleicht gibt ihr die auch nur die Videos, die es vielleicht nicht so gut erklären. Na, wobei die meisten Videos waren, it's fucking dangerous. Und dann denke ich mir auch so,
ist es nicht. Oder die KI
will angeben. Ja, guck mal, wie
krass ich bin, wie gefährlich ich bin.
Und das nächste Video, glaubst du, du entscheidest
dich für das nächste Video? Nein, tust du nicht.
Schau dir noch eins an, wie gefährlich ich bin.
Da sitzt so eine Artifische Tennis mit so einem
Trompetenkopf und sagt die ganze Zeit,
guckt euch, wie gefährlich ich bin.
Haha.
So, und lustigerweise waren viele Videos auch eher, wie albern künstliche Intelligenz ist und wie weird das ist. Weil es denkt ganz anders. Und da eine Forscherin hat gesagt, also in gewisser Weise hat die die These auch rausgehauen, sie hat gesagt, es erinnert sie an eine Naturgewalt. Mit künstlicher Intelligenz zu arbeiten, ist wie mit einer Naturgewalt zu arbeiten. Wer arbeitet denn mit Naturgewalten? Nee, ist wie mit einer Naturgewalt konfrontiert zu sein. Ah ja, okay. So, weil zum Beispiel, die haben überlegt, wie kann, die haben etwas Programmiert, so ein Hindernisparcours, und wie kommt ein Männchen mit Beinen möglichst schnell auf die andere Seite? Und die haben einen Fixpunkt gesagt. Und das Problem ist, dass wir die Fragen stellen. Wir müssen die formulieren, damit ein AI überhaupt antworten kann. AIs kommen ja nicht von sich aus aus eine Lösung. Wir müssen halt die ganzen Parameter definieren. Und die Lösung der AI war, ist, gut, dann ist sie einfach,
diese Beine sind kilometerweit hoch und dann fallen sie um.
Maximal wenig
Aufwand, maximal
wenig Kraft, schnellste Zeit.
Kann die Beine verlängern?
Die KI hat die Beine so weit verlängert,
dass sie zehn Kilometer nach oben ging und dann ist
einfach umgekippt ins Ziel.
Und man denkt, gar nicht dumm, genial.
Gar nicht dumm. Und ein bisschen hat mich das erinnert, noch bevor sie meinte, es fühlt sich an, als hätte man mit einer Naturgewalt zu tun, weil man kann so wenig beeinflussen, man weiß so wenig, was da zurückkommt an geballter Intelligenz, ein bisschen, dass es mich erinnert an die Evolution mit Dinosauriern zum Beispiel. Mal einmal zu sagen, here we go, das ist mal unser Versuch, so Evolution.
Und deswegen glaube ich, wenn wir der Zeitpunkt, wo wir künstliche Intelligenz so weit haben,
dass es Dinge selbst erschaffen kann, erschaffen wir damit Douglas Adams mässig unsere eigenen Erschaffer. Und dadurch die These weitergedacht, wir sind unsere eigenen Erschaffer. Also du meinst, rückwirkend haben wir dann, wir haben dann, wir werden unsere eigenen Erschaffer erschaffen haben werden. Ja, ist eine These. Wir sind nämlich Resultate einer künstlichen Intelligenz. Unser Universum ist das Resultat einer künstlichen Intelligenz, einer Zivilisation, die vor uns da war und das erfunden hat und das gemacht hat. Weil es ist inevitable, dass wir irgendwann mal eine künstliche Intelligenz an den Punkt bekommen werden, dass sie Dinge selber erschafft und selber clever ist. Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, bis sie das kann, wird sie aber weiterhin noch von uns angestochert werden und wir lachen über die dummen Antworten, die künstliche Intelligenz uns geben, wie zum Beispiel unsere Bestsellerliste, die mittlerweile die letzte Evolutionsstufe erreicht hat, nämlich ein Twitterbot. Eigentlich jede gute Idee endet zwangsläufig in einem Twitterbot. Wir wurden von einem Twitterbot, das ist meine neue These, wir wurden von einem Twitter-Bot erschaffen. Es gibt mittlerweile einen Twitter-Bot, der jede Woche eine zufällig generierte Liste an Bestseller-Titeln mit zufällig generierten Autorennamen twittert. In die Welt posaunt. Dem könnt ihr gerne folgen. Unter atbotpufo könnt ihr ihm auf Twitter folgen und der haut jede Woche zufällig generiert einen Tweet raus und das ist natürlich der erste Schritt
auch von uns, weg
von dieser Sklaverei der KI
hin zum Zufallsgenerator,
denn ich merkte schon langsam
in diesem Podcast. Glaubst du, das ist der große Kampf?
Ich glaube, es zeigt sich ja in diesem Podcast.
Der große Kampf, du stehst
für KI, ich stehe für Zufallsgenerator
und wir werden langfristig sehen,
wessen Team triumphiert. Können wir gerne auch mal in eine Sat1-fähige Show pressen, zu sagen, zwei Teams, also zwei, keine Ahnung, dann haben sie so Figuren, die gegeneinander kämpfen. Bei dir hat eine KI irgendwie die Perfekte rausgesucht. Und bei mir sind die einfach zufällig generierte Weirdos, die einfach super strange Monsterviecher mit 13 Tentakel- und die kämpfen gegeneinander und wir schauen einfach, wer gewinnt. Ich glaube, man kann das nicht machen, weil ich glaube, die haben keine Ebene, auf der sie miteinander kommunizieren und sich jemals so nahe kommen, dass sie gegeneinander kämpfen könnten. Weil dein Random Bot würde halt Namen generieren oder ein Blatt oder dann ist da halt ein Schwamm. Liegt da ein Schwamm. Ja. Und meine Artificial Intelligence hat halt Grossteile der Redaktionen umgebracht und ist halt da und ist kampfbereit und weiss, was es will. Das ist halt leider auch ein bisschen zu verkopft. Also nichts gegen das Sat1-Publikum, aber ich glaube, es ist halt ein bisschen nach Flupp, die grosse Flutschfingershow, und Hopp, die grosse Sprungschanzenshow, ist es halt schwierig zu sagen, wer wird sich durchsetzen, Künstliche Intelligenz oder Zufallsgeneratoren. Genau, und die ersten drei Stunden sind erstmal Professoren erklären, die grundlegenden Probleme. Hela von Sinn erklärt erstmal, wie ein Zufallsgenerator funktioniert. Bernard Waker und Hela von Sinn erklären, die stehen jeweils für die Teams. Und Elton moderiert das Ganze, aber weil es halt so komplex ist erstmal, wird es halt nach drei Uhr nachts ausgestrahlt. Ja, das stimmt. Aber es ist eine wahnsinnig lange Sendung. Fünf Tage. Weil bis diese weirden Kreaturen mal aufeinander zugerobbt sind, die ja beide völlig unfähig sind, dauert das ewig. Wirklich, 19 Level. Es ist unerträglich. Aber ich glaube, Zufallsgeneratoren werden die Zukunft beherrschen. Ihr könnt damit anfangen. Ufo, bot, punkt, bot, add, bot, pufo. Warum ist das so schwer zu sagen? Könnt ihr abonnieren und dann könnt ihr schon euren Wahlzettel in die Urne der Zukunft schieben, dass ihr euch aussprecht für Zufallsgeneratoren. Sind die besseren Menschen, sind die besseren Menschen, werden die... Glaubst du, wir wurden von einem Zufallsgenerator generiert? Im Grunde ist nicht auch Paarung, DNA-Mischung auch eine Art Zufallsgenerator. Ist das nicht das Gegenteil von Zufallsgeneratoren, weil es keine Regeln gibt? Nein, nein, nein, das wird in den Beutel geworfen, einmal durchgemischt, immer so durchgeschlackert und dann kommen die neuen DNA raus. Dominante und rezessive Gendinge. Nein, du kannst nicht vorherbestimmen. Sonst wären ja alle Geschwister exakt gleich. Warum? Ja, wenn es Regeln gäbe, nach denen die DNA-Stränge vermischt werden, wären alle Geschwister gleich, sind sie aber nicht. Die unterscheiden sich teilweise vehement, stark, so dass man denkt, der Bruder von Goethe kostet nichts. Aber ist das randomized? Oder ist es eher so, die Regeln sind so grob? Du hast immer diesen energischen Blick, wenn du solche Fragen stellst, starrst mich da an, da kann ich kaum antworten, da bleibt mir die Antwort im Hals zu stellen. Da bleibt dir die heisere Stimme, bleib zurück. Weil du mich so eindringlich anguckst und so mit deinen Fäusten fuchtest. Ich schau dich weg. Nee, du schaust wirklich nicht weg. Ich schau dich, ich schau dich ein, dringlich weg. Und deswegen kann ich da nicht darauf antworten. Ich weiß es nicht genau. Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Aber es scheint ein gutes System zu sein, weil es schon merkwürdig, dass es bei allen Tieren nur zwei Geschlechter gibt. Es gibt, ich stelle mir so vor, für Leute, die halt gerade so, aber es gibt nie drei. Das stimmt. Für Leute, die gerade so angefangen haben und gesagt haben, okay, lass uns mal alle Tiere angucken und dann Und dann dachten die, da gibt es bestimmt eins mit sieben Geschlechtern, eins mit dreizehn, eins mit neun. Schnecken haben, glaube ich, ein Geschlecht. Schnecken haben alles. Ein Haus, zwei Geschlechter, Partytime. Eine Yacht. Den ganzen Tag. Eine Yacht, ein Haus. Den ganzen Tag. Partytime. Einfach, was in diesem Schneckenhaus passiert, stays in das Schneckenhaus. Und die Nacktschnecken so, I don't give a fuck about that either. Party Time, Party Time. Herrlich, einfach zurückziehen, ich habe alles, was ich brauche hier. Ich habe hier alles, was ich brauche. Ich bin nackt und zwei Geschlechter. Come at me. Schneckentinder ist fucking leer. Downloads null. Schneckentinder wurde kein einziges Mal runtergeleitet. Swipes nix. Ein Swipe dauert drei Stunden und es hat noch nie einer geswiped. Noch nie. Niemals. Funktioniert nicht. Wir haben alles, was wir brauchen. Mancher, laut Jurassic Park, dieser Film begleitet diesen Podcast, aber auch vehement. Man könnte sagen hartnäckig. Ist er Fluch der Karibik ab? Ich weiß es nicht. Nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Ich habe wieder alle Fluch der Karibik-Teile geguckt, weil ich meinen Bootsführerschein machen möchte und einfach Bock hatte, die ganzen Fluch der Karibik-Teile zu re-watchen. Und mit dem Wissen, was ich jetzt habe, weil ich meine theoretische Prüfung gerade lerne, es macht noch mehr Spaß, diese Filme zu gucken. Ah, sehr gut. Weil die dort haben so häufig so halt nautische Begriffe, dass es fantastisch ist, wenn man mehr davon versteht. Die Bilge, der Achterdeck. Ah, herrlich. Alles hat andere Bedeutungen und man sagt nie das Wort, was man denkt, was man aus unserer Landratten-Sicht anwenden würde. Es gibt immer einen nautischen Begriff, ein nautisches Äquivalent. Aber es ist auch eine gewisse Arroganz. Du sagst für Landratte, ich meine, ihr sitzt auf einem Stück Holz auf dem Wasser. Habt ihr wirklich das Recht, euch so arrogant über alle anderen zu erheben, die einfach auf einem Erdball, auf einfach Erde ruhen? Ist das so dumm, ist das so dumm, am trockenen Land zu stehen? Nee, ist halt langweilig. Und das ist ja meine bisschen ... Ja, aber es geht schaukeln. Leute lieben es, in Elementen drum zu schwirren, in denen sie nichts zu suchen haben. Ja. Im Flugzeug lieben ... Ja, stimmt schon. Aber sind die erst nach der Entwicklung der Flugkraft so arrogant geworden? Weil ich glaube, Seefahrer waren immer die coolsten, mit Abstand die coolsten. Seebären, Seefahrer, Entdecker neuer Welten, fahren da durch Eisschollen, durchbrechen da, suchen neue Seewege, Abenteurer, finden neue Länder, alles cool. Bis Edgar Wright sagt, Leute, ich fliege hier hoch mit meinem hässlichen Holzgestell und bin viel schneller. Orwell, lass uns mal kurz die Flugfähigkeit erfinden, fliegen die da los und die Seefahrer, fuck. Und ab dann waren die die Coolen, weil ich glaube, in der Luftfahrt gibt es nicht so viele Begriffe, weil die sich nicht so abnähen, die müssen nämlich, ja, ja, nein, was heißt denn links in Luft in Luftfahrt? Aha, heißt auch links, da gibt es kein Steuerbord. Die brauchen so ein Bullshit nicht, weil sie die fucking coolen Lederjacken haben, weil sie die fucking Sonnenbrillen haben, weil sie die fucking coolen Malereien auf den Flugzeugen haben. Weißt du was? Schifffahrt ist so uncool. Schifffahrt ist richtig uncool geworden. Du bist so fachrogan wieder am Land. Im Wasser, im Wellen, schwellig hin und her, interessiert mich. Ich will Hochgeschwindigkeit, ich will den Düsenjet. Aber das ist doch uncool. Außer mir ist das auch ... Aber Stefan, Luftfahrt, nein, du stehst zu 90 Prozent aus Wasser. Du bist auf dem falschen Dampfer, Stefan Tietze, ja? Und du bist abgehoben. Ja, gerne. Ich glaube, die Arroganz ist ein Zeichen von Verzweiflung. Ich glaube, immer, wer sich so krampfer von anderen abheben muss, hat zu verstecken. Das kommt aus einer Unsicherheit raus. Das kommt aus einer Unsicherheit. Ich glaube, also ich hoffe, du wirst uns auch berichten, wie diese Seefahrerwelt von tiefer, tiefer Unsicherheit und Verzweiflung durchzogen ist. Aber ich kann euch sagen, ich habe die Mission, maximal viele Scheine zu erlangen. Richtig. Weil These, mehr Scheine, mehr Freiheit ist der Hashtag. Das habe ich jetzt schon vorgenommen und ich bin auf einem guten Weg. Also der Prüfungstermin ist in Sicht. Heute werde ich meinen Prüfungstermin einloggen. Wie lange hat es denn insgesamt gedauert, den Schein zu holen? Ja, nicht mal einen Monat. Nicht mal einen Monat? Für beide Scheine. Für den SBF, den Sportbootführerschein See und Binnen habe ich dann nicht mal einen Monat gebraucht. Auch Binnen, sag Innen. Binnen! Sag einfach Innen! Du brauchst dieses B nicht. Binnen, Schifffahrts,
Straßenverordnung. Weg mit dem
B. Mit dieser Abgehobenheit.
Nein, bei uns sagt man Binnen
übrigens statt innen. Na ja gut,
man sagt doch Binnen-Pluralismus. Man sagt doch
äh, äh, äh, ne, ich sag das nicht.
Ja, okay. Dann heb doch ab
und mach doch mal einen Flugschein. Aber es ist
wichtig, Namen sind wichtig, wenn man es bezeichnet.
Ich glaube, das ist ganz entscheidend. Deswegen bin ich zumindest bei den Dinosauriern noch froh, dass sie einigermaßen coole Namen haben. Wenn da jetzt jemand käme und sagt, wir nennen den Rosi oder irgendwas anderes. Schwierige Namen. Zum Beispiel, ich habe letztens ein Buch gelesen, dass irgendwann mal Wissenschaftler oder Biologen gesagt haben, lass uns mal den Namen von Fledermaus ändern. Das war in der Zeit des Dritten Reichs. Was ist Fleder? Fleder klingt wie ein Wort aus der Nautik. Ja, im Grunde schon. Das war tatsächlich in der Zeit des Nationalsozialismus, haben Biologen fernab der Kriege und allem einfach gesagt, wisst ihr was, lass uns mal jetzt vielleicht die Gelegenheit nutzen gerade und dieses dusselige Wort Fledermaus ändern, weil das sind keine Mäuse, die haben nichts.
Es sind ein bisschen Fleder und keine Maus.
Die haben nichts mit Mäusen zu tun und haben deswegen beschlossen, Fledermäuse sollen jetzt umbenannt werden und zwar sollten Fledermäuse umbenannt werden in Flederer. Flederer? Flederer. Es sollte nicht mehr Fledermaus heißen, sondern Flederer. Warum nicht einfach Fleder? Es ist ja das, was sie tun. Flederer, Fleder. Du meinst die Fledern rum? Sind Mäuse, die Fledern? Deswegen sind es ja Flederer. Es sind Hunde oder Mäuse, die Fledern? Also es wird auf jeden Fall gefledert. Und sie haben gesagt, Fleder ist kein Problem, die Maus stört uns leider, Maus weg. Lasst ihr uns umbenennen in Flederer. Und dann hat Hitler höchstpersönlich den Brief geschrieben und mehr oder weniger gesagt,
habt ihr eigentlich einen kompletten Schaden?
Da war bei ihm die Grenze.
Da war bei ihm die Grenze, er hat gesagt, habt ihr einen Schaden, wir benennen die
wieder zurück in Fledermaus.
Jeder hat sich an Fledermaus gewöhnt, wir bleiben bei Fledermaus.
Weißt du, warum, weil er Opern-Fan war und Richard Strauss nicht an den Karren fahren wollte? Dann passen die Reime nicht mehr, der reimt Haus auf Fledermaus. Haus Flederer. Aber ich finde es so gut, dass er einfach da sagt, ne, hört mal auf mit dem Quatsch da hinten. Aber dass da für ihn eine Grenze erreicht war, für Hitler war er die Grenze des guten Geschmacks erreicht. Ja, wirklich. Also das geht nicht. Also Flederer, das kommt. Hitlers Grenze des guten Geschmacks liegt bei Flederer und Fledermaus, dazwischen. Aber das muss auch verrückt sein. Stell dir vor, du liest die Zeitung, liest, was Leute so machen und du kannst potenziell jedem sagen, nee, lass das mal, hör auf mir damit. Mach das wieder zurückgängig, mach das wieder zurückgängig. Im Prinzip bräuchten wir für unsere Dino-Diskussionen Hitler. Eigentlich bräuchten wir so jemanden, der sagt, Quatsch, weg da mit der Trompete. Eine Form von Hitler bräuchten wir. Weg da mit der Trompete. Ja. Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob das unserem Hashtag-Aktivismus nicht vielleicht ein Bein stellen könnte. Wir brauchen so eine Art Hitler. Ja, verpack das lieber mal nicht in Hashtag. Im Kontext ist völlig okay. Verpack das lieber nicht in Hashtag. Solange es kein Hashtag ist, ist alles okay. Im Hinterkopf kannst du das immer mitdenken, aber nicht in den Hashtag bitte, sonst haben wir ein Riesenproblem. Okay. Aber das war schon so einfach, nee, hört mal auf damit, lass das mal. Nee, wie heißt es wieder Fledermaus? Ich meine, könnten... Aber das heißt ja, jetzt rückblickend, dass Fledermaus in Hitler... Im Grunde, ja, eigentlich müsste man... Sich jetzt überlegen, es wieder in Flederer umzubinden.
Also entweder ihm danken, weil Flederer
klingt einfach so dermaßen bescheuert,
oder einfach wirklich sagen,
ich meine, und auch so, ich will ja nicht sagen,
die Fledermaus ist ja in den letzten Jahren,
hat ja nicht nur
positive Schlagzeilen geleistet,
ob da nicht auch
1 plus 1, ich will nicht sagen.
Ob da nicht auch 1 plus 1, 4 ist. R. Ob da nicht auch 1 plus 1, 4 ist.
Richtig.
Fledertier, was hältst du von Fledertier?
Aber ich glaube, du darfst nicht zu vielen Tieren das Wort Tier geben.
Weil das ist ja klar, dass es ein Tier ist, wenn du dann einfach sagst.
Ich finde Fledermaus gar nicht so blöd.
Nee, Fledermaus ist super.
Es ist eine Maus mit Flügel.
Ja, aber das ist so blöd, dann kannst du ja auch die Maus, Fledermaus ohne Maus sagen. Das ist ja immer albern, das ist ja unfair, Tiere nach anderen Tieren zu. Flederlose Maus. Der Ameisenbär zum Beispiel wird benannt nach dem, was er isst. Wie lame ist das denn? Faultier. Ist nach dem benannt, was es isst. Schnabeltier. Vor allem, eigentlich der absolut mit Abstand demütigste Name ist doch wirklich Gürteltier. Oder Murmeltier. Naja, Murmeltier hat zumindest noch eine gewisse Integrität, aber wir benennen das Tier nach dem, was wir aus dem Tier machen, nachdem wir es getötet haben. Das sieht aus wie ein Gürtel, oder? Ja, Gürteltier. Warum heißt Tiger dann nicht Taschenkatze? Bringen die Leute nicht auf dumme Ideen,, okay? Bring die nicht auf dumme Ideen. Kaviarfisch. Ja, zum Beispiel. Krokodil. Handtaschen. Handtaschen. Handtaschen-Eidechse. Handtaschen-Kriecher. Kann sein, ja. Stiefelkriecher. Stiefelring. Kann alles sein, kann alles sein. Aber das nur mal ganz kurz zum Nachdenken. Angebracht, passt bitte, bitte höllisch auf, wenn ihr Dinge benennt, weil es kann dazu führen, dass die Dinge unbeliebt werden oder es kann dazu führen, dass die Dinge ein Riesenerfolg werden. Ich schau mal mein Ziel, irgendwas noch mal zu benennen. Nicht nach mir, aber irgendwas mal zu benennen. Und deswegen, da bin ich noch auf der Suche. Wo es dann, wo man, also es gibt ja so viele Leute, die einen Weltrekord aufstellen, der irgendwie einfach zu brechen ist oder sowas und danach Ausschau halten. Ich würde gerne gucken, was am einfachsten mal zu benennen. Eine Pflanzenart zu finden, was am einfachsten zu benennen. Ja, es ist die Frage, willst du was benennen, sodass Leute auch wissen, dass du es benannt hast oder eher so um die Ecke? So um die Ecke für mich zu wissen. Ich habe eine Tierart entdedeckt an Planeten. Ja, weil zum Beispiel hat ja jemand so ein neues chemisches Medikamentmittel entdeckt und hat es nach seiner Frau benannt, die hieß Rita und es hieß Ritalin. Ja, Ritalin. Rita. So, wo du auch denkst, da kommst du erstmal nicht drauf, aber wäre das was für dich? So die Titzesäure. Ja, wäre sowas um die Ecke. Titzerin oder irgendwie Titzerin.
Das klingt gar nicht so schlecht. Titzerino klingt ein bisschen wie so eine Kinderzeitschrift. Nitrotitzerin eigentlich. Das wäre der Name deiner Autobiografie, oder? Nitrotitzerin. Und du so mit verschränkten Armen vorne drauf, mit so einem Bauarbeiterhelm auf. Ja, und so einem Shirt, wo das auch nochmal drauf draufsteht. Genau, wo das Buch abgebildet ist, wo das auch noch mal draufsteht und du einfach Arme verschränkt, aber trotzdem mit beiden Daumen Thumbs Up. Du hast die Arme verschränkt, gibst aber trotzdem Doppel Thumbs Up und hast so einen, was wollt ihr dagegen machen, Blick? Nitrotecerin. Mein Leben, mein exklusives Leben. Mein Leben am Limit, mein exklusives Leben kurz vor der Detonation. Erschieden im Kiwi-Verlag. Erste Auflage. Allererste Auflage. Es gab nur eine Auflage. Finde ich gut, aber das ist doch für dich auch nochmal eins, oder? Ein Buch schreiben? Nö, gar nicht. So ein Prospekt zumindest, ein kurzer Prospekt. Ich überlege jetzt schon, wie ich die Zeit auf dem Meer rumbekomme, also ich überlege jetzt schon, wie lange ich wohl brauche, wenn ich mal nach Island rüberfahre oder über den Atlantik, nach Amerika und überlege jetzt schon, was ich da mache in dieser Zeit, wenn ich da einhändig mit meinem Kreuzer drüber segle. Aber ist es nicht törig zu denken, du könntest auf dem Schiff lesen, wird einem da nicht schlecht? Es ist nicht törig zu denken, man kann durchaus lesen auf dem Schiff. Ah, verstehe. Aber da muss man ein bisschen trainieren, oder? Der Bildsch. Okay, alles klar. Ich wünsche dir viel Spaß bei deinen Scheinen. Erzähl auf jeden Fall, wie es weitergeht. Ansonsten wünsche ich dir eine fantastische Woche. Euch natürlich auch, liebe Leute da draußen. Ja, habt eine fantastische Woche. Geht mal raus, geht mal rein, macht mal irgendwas. Denkt an die Paläontologen, haut rein, macht's gut. Nicht wegschauen. Ciao, macht's gut, tschüss. It's the worst part of the rush. April 1923, Arktischer Ozean. Es wird noch lange dauern, bis ein Schiff kommt. Hey, wir sind Ohl und Hore und das war ein Ausschnitt aus einer typischen Folge unseres Podcasts Wild und Fremd. Wir erzählen die Geschichten von historischen Expeditionen, von Abenteurerinnen und Entdeckern, ganz eng an ihren persönlichen Tagebüchern.
Wenn ihr Bock habt auf krasse, wahre Storys über wilde, fremde Welten, dann gebt Wild und Fremd im Podcast Player eurer Wahl ein.